Today for our experts
and emotion interview.
We have the pleasure of speaking with
Dr Maya to Mirror on the dark side of
positive emotion.
Dr Tamir is an assistant professor and
the director of the emotion and self
regulation laboratory at the
Hebrew University of Jerusalem.
She completed her undergraduate
degree at Tel Aviv University,
received her phd from the University
of Illinois at Urbana Champagne and
completed her post doctoral
training at Stanford University.
Dr Tamir is most interested
in understanding what
motivates people to regulate
their emotions and in her quest she
studies the implications of both pleasant
and unpleasant emotional experiences
and people's beliefs, thoughts,
and feelings about emotions.
So I'll now turn to a very special
emotion and expert interview with my
colleague, Dr Maya Tamir on the
dark side of positive emotion.
So welcome Maya.
Thanks for speaking with us today.
Thanks for having me.
That's very nice of you.
Oh,
well you're the nice one here.
So I just wanted to start by asking you
a little bit about your journey into the
world of emotions.
Sort of what first got you started or
excited to think about getting into this
topic in the first place?
Life
life is imbued with emotions.
Emotions are probably the most
wonderful thing in lights.
They can be the most
terrible thing in life.
I think we're all students of
emotion or in many, many ways.
And um,
I guess I just decided to study
emotions as a scientist as well,
was all very natural.
That's wonderful. And you're
right. Life is imbued with emotion.
So how could it not attract your
attention to want to understand it? Right.
I mean, I really think we're all, we
all study emotions all the time, right?
It's just that some of us do it in
a laboratory in, some of us don't.
That's a really good point.
I love it.
So since you've decided to embark into
studying emotions in the laboratory,
you've done a lot of
a really amazing work.
And I want to ask you just a
little bit about it today. Um,
so one of the things I wanted to
ask you about is your work that has,
um, you know, scientifically
demonstrated that positive emotions,
contrary to what most of us might think
are not always adaptive and can actually
be disadvantageous in
specific circumstances such
as your work suggests may be
engaging in competitive tasks.
And so I wonder if you could say a little
bit about how positive emotions seem
to be less adaptive in
this kind of context?
Well, according to some theories, um,
specific emotions have evolved to help us
cope with specific types of challenges.
And so,
um,
if you think about the types of
challenges that we've confronted in our
evolutionary past, um, one
of them was to avoid threats.
And so you could argue that maybe fear
has evolved as a way to help us avoid
threats.
And another type of challenge was to
fight with enemies over resources.
And so anger has evolved to help
us effectively fight enemies.
And another type of challenge is actually
to form collaborations with people who
want to,
who want to work with us.
And so one of the things that happened
this may do is help us get close to
others and work with others. So, um,
if you think about emotions
very broadly in that sense, um,
emotions can be good in some contexts
and not very good. And others,
and it's funny because when we talk
about emotions, we use these terms,
we use the terms positive emotion
and use the term negative emotions.
And when that's implied by that is that
some emotions are good and some emotions
are bad,
but that's not necessarily true.
It's not necessarily true for any
emotion and it's not necessarily true for
positive emotion. Um, we've learned in,
in my lab and in many
other labs that study, um,
cooperation and competition that when
you need to collaborate with somebody
else,
being happy is actually
very useful because it helps
you connect with others and
trust others.
But when you need to fight in happy
is actually not particularly adaptive
because it makes you trust people that
you shouldn't trust. So in some contexts,
happiness can be very useful
and others not so much.
Interesting.
So if you think of,
it sounds like the take home lesson of
what we can learn about positive emotion
is that it really depends on the context
as to whether or not it can be useful
for us or less useful. Is
that right? Right. Excellent.
Um,
and I mean on this fan,
I know you and I have worked on a paper
with one of our lovely colleagues,
I'm doctor Iris Mouse and really trying
to delineate the different ways that
positive emotion can be disadvantageous,
which people have coined the dark side
of happiness. And I wonder, you know,
from this work that we've done together
what you think of as, you know,
the guiding principles that dictate,
you know,
both when and how positive emotion might
not always be to our best advantage.
Well, the key for me
when I think about, um,
about emotions and adaptation is that
really we fool ourselves into thinking
that some emotions are necessarily
positive or good into emotions are
necessarily negative or or that,
and so when you think about
positive emotions, um,
they, they are often very good,
but they can also be bad at times.
They can have a dark
side. Um, for example,
we know that some positive emotions
are, um, better than others.
For example,
humoristic pride is a wonderful example
when you think that you're the best
person around,
well that could feel wonderful,
but it can have negative consequences
for your social relationships. Um,
there could be emotions
that are, um, uh, pleasant,
but, um, they're not, um,
desirable according to your culture.
For example, we know that pride in,
um, cultures such as the
u s are wonderful to feel,
but in cultures such as China,
uh, they're not as desirable.
And so there might be types of positive
emotions that are better than others.
But even if we put aside all those
positive emotions that we think are not as
good,
um,
even the best positive emotion could
be wonderful in some context and not in
others. Like, um, um, well
we talked about before,
even if you feel love or joy in a way,
it might be detrimental if you experienced
in a contest of calls for a very
different type of emotion.
Right? As we mentioned before,
we talked about collaboration.
We said that if you're,
if you're entering a field of enemies,
um,
maybe being cheerful is not
the best thing at that moment.
Maybe you need to be a little cautious,
a little frightened maybe, right?
Maybe you need to be angry in order
to just like where your rights in that
context.
Um,
so you want to experience the
right type of positive emotion.
You want to feel the right time of
positive emotion in the right context.
And like anything else in life,
you want to experience
positive emotion in moderation.
If you experience positive emotions
into an extreme, um, that can,
that can be very, um, that
can be very harmful. Um,
we know that there's lovely work on um,
uh,
intensity and frequency of positive
emotions showing that if you,
um, experienced, very intense, um,
very frequent positive emotions,
you may be actually a little bit
less satisfied with your life.
Then if you experience just a little
bit less African positive emotions,
if you experienced very, very
intense positive emotions, uh,
it may have some negative consequences.
For example,
it may make it very rigid.
It made me keep focus on yourself
and ignore others. It May,
I'll make you prone to take risks,
even unnecessary risks.
And you do,
you've done lovely work linking intense
positive emotions to I'm psychopathology
showing for example, that um,
intense positive aspect is,
is characteristic of manic individuals.
And so everything in moderation,
I think that I think that's
the right thing to do. So,
so if you asked me know
what my recommendation
would be for people who have
tried to pursue happiness
or positive emotions,
the right type of positive emotions in
the right context and in the right amount.
Beautiful.
And it sounds like at the end of the
day we all come back to Aristotle's,
you know, ancient wisdom about
all these three principles.
So thank you so much to my, uh, um, what
I wanted to ask you about was just the,
I mean you have so many
different lines of exciting work,
so it's hard to pinpoint what are the
questions just to speak with you about
today. But one of the things that
I wanted to make sure to what
you're very nice,
well you're very nice but not
too nice and not too friendly,
not always,
not always in every context.
Um,
but you've done some really interesting
work on instrumental emotion regulation,
you know,
demonstrating that people might not
always want to feel good actually and that
sometimes they may actually want to
experience pleasant emotions whereas other
times they may not want to experience
pleasant emotions and may actually want to
experience unpleasant emotions.
So I wondered if you could flesh
out this interesting and perhaps
counterintuitive, finding too many
people out there in the audience.
I like the word the word positive and
negative in good and bad cause I think
they have many different implications.
The question that I've been interested
in for a while now is what do people want
to feel?
Because if we think about emotion
regulation and we think about times in our
lives when we want to change how we feel,
I think that immediately we think about
those times when we try to be less
nervous or less angry,
are happier.
And we rushed to ask me, well,
what, what's the strategy? Right?
What would be the way for me to get
rid of one emotional state and embrace
another?
Um,
but if we want to understand how and
why people regulate their emotions,
we first need to understand what it
is that they want to feel in different
contexts. And, um,
I do think actually that
people want to feel good.
It's just that I think that there's
several different definitions of what,
you know,
one obvious definition,
especially if you think about
emotions involves pleasure.
What do we think about positive emotions?
And when we think about feeling
good or feeling good emotions,
and we typically think about emotions
that are pleasant to feel. But if you,
um, walk on the, um,
on campus at Yale and we grab an
innocent student and ask them,
define good to me, you're telling
me what's good. I Dunno if,
if the only answer you get is pleasure,
right? Because when we think about good,
we think about a variety of things.
We think about things that are helpful
or things that are useful or things that
are meaningful. And that's also
part of good. And so what, um,
when I think about emotion
regulation and the,
and the emotions that people want to feel,
I think people want to feel
emotions that are pleasant,
but they also want to feel emotions
that would bring about that those things
that are good for them. They want to
feel emotions that are useful. Uh,
they want a few emotions that are helpful.
They want to feel emotions
that are meaningful and
these different emotions are
not necessarily pleasant to feel
they can be, but not necessarily.
So, um, I think that the people,
people seek happiness,
um,
but they seek those things that make
them happy rather than happiness per se.
And we can think about emotions as
a toolbox, right? That as, as, as,
as a box of tools that help us attain
those goals that are important to us.
And we've done some research showing
that when people have a specific goal,
like when they want to achieve something,
um,
they want to do well on a
test or they want to, um,
um, get the most in a negotiation
or they want to do well.
On a computer game, they
can pick different types
of emotions that will help,
that will help them optimize or
maximize those outcomes that they,
that they want. Um, and these
emotions can be good or pleasant.
These emotions can be unpleasant,
but they're good in the sense that
they're helpful when we spoke to them.
That's so interesting.
I mean,
it makes me wonder kind of
what are the implications.
This research has really teasing apart,
pleasant and unpleasant from good and bad,
which is so important.
And I feel like it's so
rarely done in the literature,
which is why what you do is just
so, so crucial here. You know,
what implications do you
think this has for, you know,
the kind of emotional goals people set
for themselves and ultimately their
wellbeing at the end of the day?
Well, the one distinction we
need to, we need to make is,
is to what extent do I only
care about how I feel right now?
And that's a very valid and important
goal versus to what extent do I care about
longterm outcomes? When you care
about how you feel right now,
what you want to do is you want to change
what you feel right now to something
that, that, that you,
that you want, right?
Then typically you want
to feel good in the mud.
We want to feel pleasure in the moment.
We want to get rid of things that are
unpleasant but as soon as we look at our
lives kind of in a,
in as a longer process and
we do that all the time,
right? We do that by going to school
and spending a lot of time studying,
you know,
late at night even if you don't like it
because we care about those longer term
goals,
right?
We do that when we fight with a partner
or go to an opera or to a ball game even
though we don't want to because we
care about a relationship that's,
that's long term and I think that um,
emotions are very,
are very similar to that.
If all we think about is just the current
moment and all they think about is
feeling good right now, we may end up
hurting ourselves in the long term.
But if we think about life in the longer
term and we make sure that we use our
emotions in ways that are
helpful for our longterm goal,
um, then I think we can maximize
a longterm happiness. Um,
so
that's lovely. So when you think then
about where the sort of face of, uh,
emotion in the future,
kind of where it's, um,
based on some of the research you've
done and sort of what got you hooked into
this field in the first place,
where do you see,
where do you see the next important
steps for the future of emotion in your
humble opinion?
Um, well, um,
you know,
I think that the field of emotion as a
whole has made some incredible strides in
the past 10 years or so. And, um,
and I wouldn't be surprised if,
you know, in the next 10 years, um,
research is going to come out.
That's going to change the way that
we understand what emotions are,
how they work, um, what
the, what the, what,
what mental processes are,
um, how things work together,
what's the difference between different
mental processes? And I think that,
you know,
it's very similar to kind of how we,
how we begin our conversation by saying
that we use words and we think that
these words reflect reality,
right?
We use the word positive emotion and
negative emotion and that helps us make,
you know, very, very
clear sense of reality.
But I think that no reality is
very, it was very complex and, um,
and I think that it's particular,
particularly true about emotion. So I,
I think we're gonna,
we're gonna discover some amazing,
truly kind of groundbreaking,
um,
shattering discoveries about,
about what emotions are. Um,
I think we're going to discover
some amazing things about pleasure.
I think we're going to discover some
amazing things about what a pleasure,
pleasure and emotions
work together. Um, um,
what the role of pleasure is, how
it's formed, what it does. So I, I,
I look forward to it, but I,
maybe I made the wrong completely.
Uh,
I highly doubt that.
But when you think about sort of
where the field is headed, I mean,
obviously you'll be a part of that and
all the current colleagues we have in our
field will,
but the ones that are going to take
this to the next generation will be the
students at this moment,
you know,
or those who are considering maybe
pursuing, you know, studies and emotions.
So when you meet with your students
and they sort of ask you for advice or
they're thinking about embarking
in the field of emotion,
what advice do you usually give them?
Uh, well if you asked me about the advice
that I give my own students, I say,
stay in the lab, work hard and
do what I, no, I'm kidding.
Um,
I think,
I think the best advice
I can give people is,
um, to be bold, um,
to challenge ideas, uh, to
challenge basic assumptions,
um, not to spirit, to go against the
spring, the stream. Because I think that,
you know,
that's the way to discovery
and to enjoy the process.
Because if you don't want to have
fun doing science, then don't do it.
So I think that's my,
that's my place. How Fun.
And people,
I love that.
And just remembering to enjoy the process.
I think it's something that maybe
not enough people really emphasize.
And it's lovely that you give that
advice to students because you're right,
why would we be here in the first
place if we didn't enjoy it?
And it's wonderful,
isn't it?
It is science and especially emotion
science is a really beautiful thing.
Yup. Well, thank you Maya,
for speaking with us today.
You can do so this concludes our experts
in emotion interview with Doctor Maya
Tamir from the Hebrew
University of Jerusalem.